[Music]
another afghan provincial capital just
south of kabul has fallen to the taliban
in an offensive that's shown few signs
of slowing the latest is sharana in the
eastern province of paktika videos from
the taliban appear to show the fighters
releasing inmates from a prison but as
they advance people are scrambling for
safety afghans are pouring into kabul
from areas captured by the taliban
fearful of living under taliban rule the
u.n is warning of an unfolding
humanitarian catastrophe
specifically reports
all right let's take you actually now to
afghanistan where ashwagandha the
president is speaking let's listen to
what he's saying to the problems of the
internal displaced people
national
security and defense forces
who are defending the nation
i'm thankful for them i'm thankful to
the
nation
our first priority is to bring
coordination
and swift actions in relation to
coordinating our
and dsf
our national security and defense forces
i would like to assure you
as your president
i know you are worried about the
situation we are going to
prevent
further displacement of the people
and
the situation for the people
i'm not going to allow this imposed war
on our nation to lead to more
bloodshed
and to
losing the gains
of our last two decades and to damages
to our
public goods and infrastructure because
of this
i've carried out
consultations widespread comprehensive
consultations with the representatives
of the people and leaders
and with our
international partners
consultations are being carried out
in a speedy manner i'm going to share
the results with you
quickly
your well-being your health
your success and prosperity are our
concerns our priorities we are going to
continue our efforts long live
afghanistan
let's go now live to rob mcbride in
kabul so rob there we heard quite a
defiant message from ashraf ghani put it
into context what is the bottom line of
his assurances to people
well yeah we've been all expecting this
speech from ashraf ghani he has become
increasingly embattled
by this crisis uh there has been an
awful lot of speculation that there
might be some kind of change in
leadership that he might announce even
possibly that he might be standing back
from government that's what the uh
speculation has been about leading up to
this speech uh the the the but as we've
heard there he seems to have recommitted
himself uh to carrying on the struggle
he
came on thanking the uh the the armed
forces for the sacrifices that they have
made he has uh talked about trying to
prevent further bloodshed and suffering
uh of the people he's spoken about not
giving up all of the advances and the
the the gains that have been made over
the last 20 years or so but that was it
that was the end of the speech and it's
very interesting because there has been
an awful lot of pressure on him that
there has to be some sort of political
solution to this it's not going to be
settled on the battlefield and the
political solution might involve him
stepping back and somebody else taking
over certainly that's been the demand
from
organizations like the taliban they will
have said repeatedly that if they're
going to talk about any power sharing
agreement then ashraf ghani is not going
to be part of that picture but as we've
heard there i don't know if this is
going to change anytime soon but for the
moment at least he seems committed
all right thanks so much to rob mcbride
there let's bring in victoria fonten
professor of peace studies at the
american university of afghanistan joins
us now on skype
from kabul good to have you with us if i
could start with a point that
president ashraf ghani mentioned there
without elaborating he did say
consultations are underway
what exactly do we understand that to
mean are these consultations and
negotiations for a transition to a
different government
well that could be the case uh because
this is something that the afghan
government has already proposed
a few days ago
and
and it could be uh that uh that this
solution could end uh the current
violence however uh the taliban have
asked for ashwagandha to step down
and have already rejected uh this type
of negotiated settlement so it remains
to be seen uh what happens with the
position of president ghani
it's so it has been suggested that the
uh
there is a mediation
effort underway led by ismail khan
to try and talk directly to the northern
alliance might that lead to a transition
transitional government that
does not include ashraf ghani as your as
you are pointing out there
uh well um th this this could well
happen i don't think that we have any
information to uh uh to speculate on
that uh at this time uh but again um uh
it's all about the current government
its legitimacy and uh and also the stand
that it is going to take in the next 24
hours so if this government um if the
president does not step down then does
it mean that
we have different political factions uh
um claiming uh to be uh the legitimate
rulers of afghanistan at in the middle
of a war uh nobody knows right now and
uh and i guess that uh the next hours
are going to be crucial the situation is
unfolding really rapidly here and
and there has been a lot of speculation
about the uh stepping down of president
ghani but so far
it all remains to be seen
overall the tone of president ashraf
ghani's message there was quite defiant
saying he will protect the people he
will not allow the gains of the last
couple of decades to be lost and so on
and so forth from your analysis though
with the latest gains made by the
taliban
can the government resist can it
withstand this taliban tide
i do not think it can
there is a lot of talk in kabul about
the impeding impending independent
states on thursday and many think that
the taliban are going to
go for kabul this week and declare
independence on thursday so i their
latest games are extremely significant
they're going for mazar sharif right now
and
and it's uh it's time for a negotiated
settlement uh
every minute every hour counts
and uh it's um i think that the
situation is so critical
uh those advances um are unlikely to
stop unless um the demands are being met
and that's uh extremely um unfortunate
what sort of posture do you expect from
the international community particularly
the us
um i don't quite know because
every time
they they indicate to the taliban not to
cross a certain boundary that boundary
is crossed and there is still uh
negotiations and uh and uh and there are
still uh agreements sought and there is
still a lot of uh in a way diplomatic
cajoling and so um i i i simply don't
know what to expect right now uh the uh
the focus is on
the evacuation of of embassy staff um
and i i think that the disengagement is
uh quite clear and has been clear for
some time and um and there is also from
that perspective uh a lot of defiance
and in transitions too and so in a
conflict where different parties are not
willing to budge then this of course
needs uh um
an open boulevard leaves an open
boulevard for the taliban to just
advance onto kabul and uh and and for
the winner to take it all really
all right thank you so much for your
analysis on that